on connaît on les a identifié les
facteurs de risque c'est c'était
beaucoup l'âge maintenant on a une
augmentation de 25% des AVC chez les
personnes de moins de 50 ans donc c'est
ça devient chez les gens de plus en plus
jeunes et il y a plusieurs facteurs de
risque il y a l'âge il y a le tabac il y
a le cholestérol il y a le surpoids il y
a le et évidemment la consommation de
substances comme la cocaïne juste
comment on sait quelles sont les
symptômes comment on peut sentir qu'on
fait un AVC alors on peut avoir
plusieurs types de symptômes on peut
avoir des symptômes des petites semaines
d'alarme qui vont vous prévenir
c'est-à-dire tout à coup vous avez des
difficultés à parler des petites fourmis
des petits troubles moteurs le pied qui
lâche un petit peu et ça ça doit
vraiment vous alerter parce que même si
c'est transitoire c'est-à-dire pendant 5
minutes vous avez ça oui parce qu'en
fait tout dépend on va revenir un petit
peu en arrière il y a plusieurs types
d'AVC n'avait C c'est quand il y a une
artère du cerveau soit qui se bouche
soit qui va saigner et selon le
territoire où ça va se passer les
neurones ne vont plus être irrigués
oxygénées et donc ne vont plus
fonctionner et ça va très vite on peut
perdre 2 millions de neurones en une
minute et donc suivant je vous rassure
on a fait 10 millions 30 secondes on a
86 milliards de neurones dans le cerveau
c'est de comprendre que le temps compte
énormément les Anglo-Saxons disent time
is brand parce qu'en fait dès que vous
perdez du temps vous perdez des neurones
et après ça peut devenir irréversible et
donc suivant l'endroit l'endroit dans le
cerveau où ça se passe évidemment on va
avoir des signes différents si c'est la
zone de la parole ben on va pouvoir
parler si c'est la zone de la vision
d'avoir des troupes de la vue motricer
la sensibilité on va avoir des des
fourmis des engourdissements j'avais des
fourmis dans les mains moi mais c'est
parce que comme je joue beaucoup
peut-être
là
on connaît la cause mais on peut avoir
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
c'est très important parce qu'on
communique pas assez là dessus les
accidents ischémiques transitoires c'est
une sonnette d'alarme c'est qu'en fait
vous pouvez avoir ça puis ça disparaît
donc vous dites c'est rien du tout
justement aller en
puisque c'est tout dépend vraiment de
l'endroit dans le cerveau en général
quand c'est la parole c'est au niveau de
l'hémisphère gauche que ça se passe mais
ça peut être partout ça peut être moteur
ça peut être sensitif ça peut être
absolument toujours pour autant
oui absolument le faire parce qu'en fait
on ne sait jamais comment ça va évoluer
et on sait surtout que chaque seconde
compte bien sûr
est-ce qu'un AVC peut être suivi
d'autres dans énormément de cas où
est-ce que il y a un AVC et puis plus
rien après ah non on sait qu'il peut y
avoir des récidives justement après
parce qu'en fait en général il y a des
facteurs de risque donc les facteurs de
risque vous n'allez pas des éliminer
juste après votre AVC donc il se perdue
et c'est pour ça que quand une personne
a un AVC je vous signale quand même
qu'il y a 150 000 AVC par an et il y a
30 personnes sur six qui aura un AVC
dans cette
là il y en a trois et surtout et surtout
il y a 30000 décès par an mais surtout
sur les personnes qui ne se font pas
partie de ces décès il y en aura une sur
deux qui aura des séquelles donc ça
c'est important et effectivement pour
répondre à votre question on a des
risques de récidiver et c'est pour ça
qu'on va mettre en place tout un
traitement derrière un AVC pour éviter
justement ces risques sans dix mille
personnes sont hospitalisées chaque
année à cause d'un AVC environ 30% des
patients des cèdent dans l'année suivant
l'AVC 15% des patients décèdent dans le
mois suivant l'admission à l'hôpital
ça fait ça fait flipper quand même et on
a l'impression que c'est que les hommes
les femmes aussi
le prix de 70% déclare avoir des
séquelles de leur avc un AVC sur deux
entraîne un handicap moteur ou trouble
du langage seulement 4 victimes d'AVC
sur 10 reprennent une activité
professionnelle à plein temps après un
AVC et après ça c'est les trous de
moteur mais il y a aussi les troubles
psychiques avec de fortes dépressions
après un AVC parce que ça touche aussi à
toute la sensibilité et aux émotions et
tout ça donc c'est vraiment très lourd
on ressort jamais un des
non parce qu'on a enfin d'elle on peut
tout récupérer de matière de la
motricité etc on peut tout récupérer
mais c'est un choc de toute façon et
est-ce que si on en a fait un voilà qui
a été important est-ce qu'après on est
tranquille ou ça veut rien dire c'est la
loterie on peut revenir on peut refaire
un ou à quelqu'un
ou pas du tout plus de risques de
refaire après il faut absolument arrêter
tous les facteurs de risque le tabac est
un des principaux facteurs de risque
vous venez de parler du tabac juste
avant le tabac il y a des gens qui
fument pas qui se droguent pas qui
boivent pas qui ont des ABC aussi non
vous avez beaucoup moins de risques
d'enfer si vous avez une si vous me
suivez pas si vous n'avez pas de
surpoids si vous n'avez pas de
cholestérol pas de chance
je suis un monstre je le savais oui
est-ce que chez les femmes la prise de
certains contraceptifs peuvent peut
vraiment augmenter le risque tous les
ennemis des vaisseaux peuvent augmenter
les risques donc certaines
contraceptives aussi d'anciennes
génération on va pas faire peur à tout
le monde des nouvelles pilules beaucoup
moins malheureusement les nouvelles
pilules ne sont pas prises en charge et
les anciennes oui et surtout pilule plus
cigarette alors là c'est bon dangereuse
[Musique]
est-ce que il y a 40 ans il y avait plus
d'AVC que maintenant est-ce que c'est
notre mode de vie qui a changé par
rapport à cigarette par rapport à ce
qu'on mange puisque
il y a 30 ans il y a 30 ans j'avais pas
l'impression qu'on entendait tout le
temps des AVC
vieillissement de la population
effectivement il y a le fait de
maintenant on a des des on sait vraiment
les diagnostiquer assez précocement et
il y a aussi c'est ce qui explique
justement que ça se passe de plus en
plus chez les jeunes la consommation de
stupéfiants maintenant quand vous voyez
arriver quelqu'un aux urgences qui a
moins de 50 ans qui a fait ou un AVC ou
un infarctus du myocarde tout de suite
on va doser la cocaïne
cannabis aussi
les deux et la sédentarité c'est un
rapport ou pas bien sûr
tous les ennemis des artères puisque ce
sont des artères qui se stabilisent
parce qu'on bouge plus beaucoup mais
arrête de poser des questions de Dieu
je suis tout le temps sur les nez bon
allez on passe tout de suite
non vous inquiétez pas je suis là et les
ondes de premiers secours vous allez
voir le 8 mars
du téléphone le soir il faut pas il faut
pas garder le téléphone à côté il faut
le mettre sur mode avion
[Applaudissements]
et c'est quelqu'un un AVC tout de suite
tout de suite tout de suite il faut
l'allonger en position latérale de
sécurité tout de suite très important
dans la vie